hey i'm lemoine morris and i'm team
murph i'm sasha zameda
and i'm blake anderson and we are the
cast of woke we're here with buzzfeed
right now playing a game of who's who
whoo
let's go
i mean
[Laughter]
do we have to do we have to as we just
all take turns going because i'm going
to go ahead and say team murph
yeah that's yeah mostly a teamwork he
pulls up to the studio a lot
here you guys like what's your name man
he goes hey what's the question again
you repeat that i will own that
there have been there have been
instances where i have may have dropped
a line
or 12. that's all i'm saying
[Music]
me purse i'm going to go ahead and say
blake only be
oh well i would say blake is most likely
you haven't done it
but looking at your background what'd
you say that i know of yet
it's a long uh a long ploy i would say
lamorne
me too yeah yeah you like do pranks in
people's faces where you're like
now i'm just talking a different
language i'm just i'm going to where
you're all the time
definitely all right i might take that
one i'll throw a monkey wrench in there
occasionally a real one
he did threw a wrench at me it was
probably i did
but to be fair you did not deserve it
thank you for being fair
[Music]
i go i gotta say bloody god
yes it ends up with some shady people i
just feel
like guthrie's not shady no but he has
shady like tendencies
he has he has some shady tendencies
blake
for me personally all three of them and
here and let me explain why
t murph will make me laugh in the middle
of potatoes he'll just love roasting you
for no reason like team earth will talk
about your pants for no reason
blake because his delivery is absolutely
hilarious like he'll get a line
sometimes that might on the page that
might just be
kind of whatever like oh cool you know
what i mean like he'll turn into a whole
bit
that'll that that will elevate the scene
and make you laugh in the middle of the
scene so shear
improvises like an [ __ ]
thank like i'll try to do a bit i'll try
to do a bit with this year and she
and she makes you own it i like that
answer i'm gonna i'm gonna ride with
that one too
[Music]
i'm gonna go with lamorne on that he's
the wokest sleepiest person
tired y'all might find me sleep right
now
i pre-taped all of this this is a
hologram yep
i'm gonna say blake blake always knew
like what the with the hot snacks they
had like like yo they got yo you need to
get over there they got and it's like
you always know
what they got you know when when in
canada and they wheel out enchiladas
you gotta try
this morning i definitely was online
trying to trying to win this new pair of
yeezys
like i had two phones my macbook like
three windows open on the mac
i lost all five
i'm just gonna go ahead and say uh
sashir just based off of her
uh her her caliber of like training and
skill and to be a pro
funny person like like t murph goes on
stage
just like you and crushes it but i'm
talking like snl type
you can do impressions probably better
than me oh thank you i was gonna say you
because you definitely try
to do impressions more than that
you definitely attempt it more often
you know i guess it only comes out when
i'm trying to make fun of people
so it's hateful
i don't think i can just name anybody
besides lamorin like
i spun a few plates in my day i'm gonna
say blake i don't know what these are
oh i thought you were going to say
massage and i was like uh i feel like
sasha would give damaging advice she
would see
if he would do it blake is usually
pretty uh sound in his advice
because blake is really quiet he's a
quiet guy and usually the quiet people
are the ones who are more observant i
must say blake for me
i would i would go with lamorne dude you
come on you spit lots of wisdom dude
i've seen you
walk teamwork through his entire career
[Laughter]
in like two minutes
it's theirs
i feel like you talk to your sneakers
and they talk back to you
feels that way at times from the looks
of blake's house i would say blake
oh yeah i mean again look behind him
i live in pee wee herman's house
if you if you get a chance folks out
there stop by blake's house pay him a
visit
open today don't invite people to his
house it's okay it's fine
it's blank he's cool he's cool
you